[Music]
on this Saturday night historic flooding
Nova Scotia slammed by record rainfall
it came fast and it came Furious the
desperate search for the missing and a
warning from officials please be patient
stay safe stay home
Crimea attacks
and takes aim at a strategic Target plus
the new app helping Canadians find a
physician networks operates kind of like
ubereats or Skip and the concerns it
could strain the struggling Health Care
system
and Menace or mischief
how these boat bumping orcas might just
be following the latest fad
global national with foreign Esser
reporting tonight Sophie Lewis
across Nova Scotia tonight there is
significant damage and heartache after
the heaviest rains in more than 40 years
a slow-moving storm dumped more than
three months worth of rain in less than
24 hours causing massive flooding across
the region a state of emergency has been
declared in five municipalities good
evening and thanks for joining us the
search is underway for four people after
two vehicles were submerged in the flood
waters two of the missing are children
there were five occupants in the vehicle
three escaped the search is ongoing for
these two children in a separate instant
a youth and another man are unaccounted
for after the vehicle that they were
traveling in was submerged
there's also significant damage to roads
and infrastructure tonight more than 6
000 homes and businesses are without
power across the province and
authorities are asking residents to stay
home if they can Sean O'Shea has our top
story The Rain came fast came hard and
with an intensity that surprised even
those who've witnessed powerful weather
here before it's been very dramatic it's
uh it's unlike anything I've seen in
just 24 hours three months worth of rain
fell sending a surge of water through
the Nova Scotia Capital One area was 280
we would normally get 90
mils a month in July so just a lot of
rain very very quickly officials say
there were hundreds of lightning strikes
at least 150 people were forced from
their homes in the greater Halifax area
thousands more lost power
as the Heavy Rain swept much of the
province causing what's been called a
historic flood event
loads turned into rivers even some
emergency crews had trouble moving this
social media video shows a fire engine
attempting to make its way through deep
water
but the water is too much and the
firefighters are stuck at one point
there were fears a hydroelectric Dam
could breach but that didn't happen some
of the worst damages west of Halifax
where roads and bridges are washed out
we lost a number of bridges and a number
of other bridges are compromised it
includes damage to 100 series highways
on the 103. it includes local roads and
and obviously
significant property damage got a server
that's seen crippling wildfires now Nova
Scotia looks to recover from one of the
worst summer storms on record we had a
pandemic we've had fires we've had
we've had floods it seems like
there have been a lot of uh incidents
lately that just kind of make you get
give you pause and this promise we will
do our very best all orders of
government as well as the amazing people
that work in the volunteer capacity in
search and rescue uh circumstances like
this uh and um you know do the right
things and we will uh we'll make it
through Shadow Shea Global News prime
minister Justin Trudeau says he is very
concerned about the flooding in Nova
Scotia he's asking residents to listen
to local authorities on how to stay safe
we're closely engaged with the
government of Nova Scotia but obviously
this is just a time where we're thinking
of families going through an incredibly
difficult moment and we will be there
for them while they're going through
this but also through the difficult days
and weeks to come on the cleanup well
the Halifax pride parade is being
postponed because of the floods the
event was supposed to be held tomorrow
but organizers say they'll reschedule in
the interest of safety and Recovery
efforts as Global's Vanessa Wright
report towards the Damage Done in the
last 24 hours could take months to
rebuild
a chaotic scene in Bedford Nova Scotia
early this morning as Friday night's
extensive rainfall turns many areas
around the region unrecognizable this is
the first time that we've been deployed
on flooding it's a high scale it's
something that I haven't seen before in
approximately 15 years to see it to this
to this extent Nova scotia's emergency
system sent out an evacuation order
early Saturday morning after reports had
more than 200 millimeters of rain
falling in Bedford alone this aftermath
left flash flooding along major
intersections and extensive road damage
finally had a chance to get down to
survey the church and this is the first
thing I've seen and I'm shocked by it
and disappointed substantial cleanup
efforts will continue for many areas
around the Halifax region including this
one behind me this baseball field in
Bedford is completely submerged in water
along with dozens of cars the flooding
collapsed the roof of Bedford Place Mall
where individuals were briefly trapped
inside died they were forced to evacuate
along with residents of an apartment
building behind the mall Regan says this
should prompt a conversation about the
city's infrastructure municipalities not
just here in HRM but elsewhere are going
to have to be thinking about
when you're starting to get Once In A
Hundred Year storms every five years
that's an issue
there are still approximately 150
residents Who Remain displaced from
their homes in the Halifax region but
the support continues to pour in two
Comfort centers have been set up in
Dartmouth and Beaver Bank for evacuees
to take shelter Vanessa Wright Global
News Bedford Nova Scotia
Global News meteorologist Peter Quinlan
joins us now and Peter the intensity of
the storm seems worse than what had been
forecast why is that Sophie part of the
reason why the models miss this historic
Heavy Rain across Nova Scotia was
because of the convective nature of this
and models typically have difficulty
with that because of the small scale
features in thunderstorms it can sit
over areas like they did over Halifax
and parts of Nova Scotia for over a
24-hour period off and on as for those
total amounts very impressive this is
the Halifax area just to the east over
300 millimeters is reported in some
areas in terms of the station's
Bridgewater reporting 252 millimeters of
moisture Halifax over 200 millimeters
and the reason why is because we've had
these above average sea surface
temperatures that fuel these kind of
convective very strong rain events a
southerly flow as well in the
combination of those features brings
about the potential for heavier rains
and near record warmth actually on the
sea surface temperature and in Halifax
it was the biggest just rained since
hurricane Beth in 1971 if you can
believe it there were thousands of
lightning strikes as you can see here
across the province and as for the where
the system is going next it's going to
exit Cape Breton tonight hit parts of
Newfoundland but it won't stall over
Newfoundland like it did over Nova
Scotia so amounts will be suppressed in
comparison only closer to 60 millimeters
around portobasque but this Ridge of
high pressure this blocking feature is
going to keep the heat around the above
average sea surface temperature
anomalies and even 30 degree
temperatures in Halifax this week but
the good news is there's no major rain
expected but the heat sticking around
means we could see more potential for
this in the coming weeks and months
Sophie all right thanks for that
meteorologist Peter Quinlan in BC a
young firefighter killed and the line of
duty was honored at a memorial service
today
[Music]
fellow firefighters and First Responders
in the city of Revelstoke marched in
procession paying tribute to 19 year old
Devin Gayle the BCA Wildfire service
member was part of a team responding to
a small fire near the city last week
when she was found trapped beneath a
tree that had fallen on her she later
died of her injuries in hospital Gail
was also a third year University nursing
student
maybe this is the call to action that we
need
finally ask ourselves if we're fine with
every summer having record-breaking
numbers of fires and record-breaking
temps and record-breaking natural
disasters
in these Summers and their fires and
their attempts won't stop just because
we lost a friend called your sister
in Ukraine troops have begun using U.S
provided cluster bombs against Russian
forces the White House says they're
helping to dislodge concentrations of
enemy soldiers but there are reports a
Russian journalist was killed when
Ukraine fired cluster Munitions keeve
also launched a drone strike at an
Ammunition Depot in russian-occupied
Crimea civilians were forced to flee and
traffic was stopped on the Kirch Bridge
a vital Supply route from Moscow it's
the latest attack since Russia suspended
a major grain deal with Ukraine earlier
this week as Mackenzie gray reports
pressure is mounting on Russia to
reverse course
after a brutal week of bombings the
Ukrainian responds
a fuel Depot inside Russian occupied
Crimea Up in Smoke
the objective is to reclaim the whole of
the Crimea because it's always Sovereign
Nation the German tackled the Moscow
installed governor of the region to
close a bridge linking the peninsula to
Russia despite the Fuel Depot being more
than 160 kilometers away
the only link from Russia to Crimea
suffered serious damage last week and
attacked the ukrainians have not taken
responsibility for but Vladimir
zielinski believes it is a legitimate
military Target the criminal bridge this
is not just a logistical Road
this is uh the roots used to
speed the war with ammunition and this
has been done on a daily basis and it
militarizes the Crimean peninsula
the attack led to Fierce Russian bombing
across Ukraine with a key focus on
Odessa the port city that was the hub
for Ukrainian grain shipments which also
stopped last week after Russia pulled
out of a deal guaranteeing the safety of
cargo ships the new wave of attacks on
Ukrainian ports risks having
far-reaching impacts on Global Food
Security in particular in developing
countries grain prices have spiked nine
percent since the rush Ukraine deal
ended which is set to hurt countries
across Africa and the Middle East hard
many of whom have stayed neutral or even
supported Vladimir Putin's war in
Ukraine Mackenzie gray Global News
coming up Need A Doctor there's an app
for that the self-proclaimed Uber Eats
of Health Care connecting Canadians with
medical experts
plus bumping boats the surprising theory
behind the rise in orca run-ins
[Music]
trying to get an appointment with a
family doctor or specialist can be
frustrating especially when so many
people don't have a primary care
physician but a Canadian app is offering
a new way to connect with care providers
at a time when there's a labor shortage
across the system Catherine Ward reports
the onset of sudden patchy hair loss was
worrying for Drew Peery I noticed a very
large bald spot coming in on the back of
my head within a handful of days it
turned into another spot and another
spot and just has progressively gotten
worse waiting for a referral to manage
what he learned was alopecia only added
to his stress I still had to wait a
couple of weeks to get in to see the
family doctor even and then the referral
process through them takes three four
months to to be finally seen by a
dermatologist a canadian-based app is
looking to streamline Care by giving
patients more Choice the problem was
very simple it's about access and
options medworks launched last year
[Applause]
now thousands of providers have joined
the growing platform patients log on and
can choose from Services Geotech to
their neighborhood consultations can be
over the phone or through video home
visits are also possible medworks
operates kind of like ubereats or skip
care providers pay a fee to access the
tools and then insurance and billing is
a conversation between them and the
patient personal information is not
stored on the app while virtual care is
not new this platform boasts a much
wider scope of Specialists everything
from paramedics to dietitians we are not
changing health care we're just
providing Access to Health Care access
to health care and providers that exist
today
I'd like to see is a real strategy to
address the family doctor shortage and
some doctors worry about how resources
will be impacted overall I think apps
like this represent the uberization of
Health Care and really distract from a
lot of the root systemic issues that we
really need to be dealing with Catherine
board Global News Toronto
[Music]
ahead the Canadian Community where
dementia patients can live with dignity
foreign
it's estimated more than 55 million
people worldwide are living with
Alzheimer's or another form of dementia
an already staggering number that's
expected to double every 20 years that's
why many across the country are
developing new models of care to ensure
those diagnosed with the disease are
given the dignity they deserve in a
story originally featured on the new
reality Farah Nasser takes us inside a
first of its kind Village in British
Columbia
two muffins and hot chocolate for you
yes please there's a community in
Langley British Columbia that may remind
you of your own
you can go for a stroll pick up a few
items at the store or even pop by the
salon
[Music]
but this Village was purposefully built
to allow for freedom and quality of life
because every resident here has
something in common
they're all living with dementia
[Music]
who's that
driving the car
it's you
it's home to Alan Maggie before moving
in Allen was a world traveler and
adventurer he climbed some of the
highest peaks on the planet and raced
cars he was even living on a boat when
he started to notice some changes it was
called the piracy and he really enjoyed
it there a lot until became too
difficult for him he couldn't remember
how to work the washing machine it was
just little things that he never had
trouble with before it became a problem
that's you Allen right there Carol Chasm
has been Alan's friend for more than 20
years she knows the village is the best
place for his adventurous personality I
think it's very important when you've
been an active person that you're in a
place where you don't feel
institutionalized where you feel a sense
of freedom and that's what you get here
in the village
Eleanor jesperson is one of the
co-founders of the village in Langley
the first of its kind in Canada he
worked in senior living for about 30
years and knew there must be a better
way to care for people with dementia
having Society first of all realize that
people with dementia are first and
foremost people
they're your family in many cases
they can live a good life a different
life perhaps but still a good life
[Music]
so the five acre Village was built with
the guiding principles to make it feel
like a neighborhood
with colorful houses a farm and even a
community center
and one of the key principles that the
village is called Rome Free we said we
need to build a community where people
can walk out the door walk around come
and go as they please and still remain
safe
Creative Solutions which focus on the
person first will be needed as rates of
dementia are steadily Rising as of 2023
nearly 700 000 people in Canada are
living with dementia and it's been
projected that that number will soar to
close to 1.7 Million by 2050.
even though Canada has a dementia
strategy the majority of care in nursing
homes is still delivered in that same
old model most of the people have some
level of Dementia in long-term care we
need to change this model in a dramatic
way we need a transformative change but
looks at the person in a more
comprehensive more holistic way
at the village in Langley Allen and
Carol are visiting the hens at the Farm
oh look at that and other villagers are
in an exercise class
good job there are 75 residents here and
it's not government subsidized so
residents pay a range from eight to ten
thousand dollars a month depending on
their care needs not everyone will be
able to afford to live in a village like
this but the hope is that this type of
care will be an example of what's
possible in the future far unaster
Global News Toronto
and you can catch up on past stories
from the new reality on our website
globalnews.ca the new reality and on the
global news YouTube channel you can also
watch full episodes anytime on the
Global TV app
next the strange rise in Orca run-ins
what experts say might be behind a surge
of goat bumpings
[Music]
well it just might be the hot fad of the
summer not for humans but for orcas in
recent weeks there have been several
reports of orcas going after boats in
some cases even sinking them the
phenomenon has some wondering whether
this is the dawn of a killer whale
Uprising but as Mike Armstrong shows us
experts say it's simply orcas playing
their newest orca game
uh coming straight there may have been a
big difference between what these
Sailors felt they were experiencing an
attack and what it likely was possibly a
game
in either case there's no question it
was scary a pot of killer whales bumped
the boat over and over
cast game of this straight at us and
they started hitting Naruto impressive
to see the orcas first of all beautiful
animal but also dangerous moment first
and a team
something strange has happened in the
last few years off the coast of Spain
and Portugal Orca interactions in the
region have exploded there were 52
reported contacts in 2020 but just two
years later there were four times as
many yeah we see them just this year
three boats have actually been sunk now
there have been jokes that there's an
orca Uprising against Rich yacht owners
and there are theories it could have
started with one whale being injured
after being hit by a boat and then
passing on the behavior and animosity to
other whales
wow we're seeing something from its
Nexus from its from its Inception it's a
phenomenon that is fascinating Orca
experts like Deborah Giles she says
killer whales are social and curious
animals and also playful Giles believes
the orcas that are bumping boats are
just fooling around I don't think that
the whales are are attacking attacking
the boats and they're certainly not
interested in the people
now experts say it's not surprising
these strange behavior is growing killer
whales do learn from each other I think
it is very fair to say that this
resembles a fad in killer whales well
researcher Michael Weiss says orcas
sometimes pick up peculiar habits one of
the strangest experts have seen was back
in 1987 off Washington State the summer
of salmon hats a female Orca started
wearing a salmon on its head and within
weeks other pods started doing it the
fad only lasted one summer they do
culturally transmit behaviors and and
strategies pretty constantly
while the incidents may be spreading
this was a yacht off Scotland last month
that was rammed multiple times killer
whales can travel long distances so it
could be an orca that learned the
behavior off Spain or Portugal but
experts can't tell Mike Armstrong Global
News
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Sophie Louis
tonight's your Canada is Calgary we love
seeing your Canada so please keep
emailing your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com